[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me start there with nick wright
kansas city chiefs apologist uh could
you see
jj watt maybe joining this show
what some believe apologist is at least
you got my name right this time dan
go ahead you were gonna ask me about jj
watt could you see him joining your
kansas city chiefs to maybe help them
win a super bowl yeah i listen
and as an added bonus for jj he could go
from a fraudulent awful barbecue city
in houston to the greatest barbecue city
in america
kansas city missouri uh and i the the
upgrade of organizations and coaches
from the bill o'brien jack easter be
reign of terror in houston
to the bret v chandy reed tightly run
ship in kansas city
it's just night and day so for all those
reasons alongside he would actually get
to you know play in and win a super bowl
those things would all be good for him
it's great to see you by the way
it's great to see you nick a couple of
things to talk to you about
i don't know if you agree with me the
jazz they
have been the best team in the nba least
record wise may not be exciting may not
have household names
it's been impressive what they did but
the lakers are click bait so
what is the headline today the lakers or
the jazz
but it's not because they're clickbait
but let me let me go to the jazz first
i heard the beginning of the segment but
i didn't hear the very very first words
out of your mouth
it was odd to me why were you spending
the open of this hour talking about the
2015 atlanta hawks
or was it the 2018 toronto raptors i i'm
not sure
it sounded a lot like that this team
listen i'm not going to go out on the
limb and say they're actually you know
going to be good in the playoffs but man
oh man
have you seen jordan jordan clarkson's
true shooting percentage
because if you don't give them the
respect if you don't understand
that georges yang is going to be just a
playoff sniper
well you're not a sophisticated area
type basketball fan
we've seen this team before okay wait
are you
not interested in the jazz because
they're not interesting
or non-threatening what's the well i
just there there's
a half dozen teams that with a gun to
your head
you would pick over them to win the
title just like the 2015 hawks remember
the 2015 hawks
they had their entire team one player of
the month
do you know why that happened because
it's like well we know none of them are
that good but they were 17-0 so we got
to give it to them
we've seen this story before it's a fun
nice cute story and i'm glad for the
people of utah that they get it but this
is not a
this is not a contender in any stretch
of the imagination
now the lakers we've also seen this
story before
do you know what this lakers team
reminds me of the first laker team
lebron was on
it's like lebron and a bunch of okay
pieces because when you don't have
anthony davis
and schroeder but more so davis that's
what this team is
and so yeah like i don't actually think
either is a huge deal
because here's what we know about the
lakers if anthony davis is not around
for the playoffs they can't win the
title
but he's gonna be around for the
playoffs so i'm not
overly concerned with it and lebron is
having
every go through his basketball
reference game log
it's usually january but he has it down
two weeks shortly before the all-star
break he's that's what's going on with
him right now and his shot has
you know failed him for the last month
it'll come back lakers will be fine
this load management with lebron
what should be the approach by the
lakers what should be the approach
by lebron i
have listen i am i'm 36 years old which
makes me a millennial but there are
certain things about me that i feel like
i am of your generation which you were
you're the silent generation
right dan i'm not sure which one uh but
uh whichever one it is
the which is i have this controversial
take for people my age
which is when healthy and available you
should go to work
lebron's healthy he's available he
should probably go to work
and lebron is in this odd
almost singular spot as an athlete which
is we operate from the perspective
of we have to criticize him so
what so if lebron was taking a lot of
time off
do we think that would be like you know
what smart good job lebron
petty play not overworking no he would
be criticized for it
lebron is now being criticized for
playing every game
now do i think guys in an 82 game season
it's smart to play all 82
probably not and lebron's only done that
in the later part of his career one time
as last year with the cavs
but i also think the league was dan
three years ago in a very dangerous spot
with the load management
do you remember the nationally televised
spurs
warriors game both teams were like on
pace for 65 wins
and nobody played kawhi didn't play kd
didn't play steph didn't play clay
didn't play
and it was becoming a trend and i think
lebron
is helping stop that because while guys
will still
rest on some back to backs if lebron
jumped on the kawhi leonard from last
year load management plan
then it would become even more accepted
and that'd be terrible for the business
of basketball
so i think lebron is responsibility was
teammates and a bigger responsibility to
the league
to kind of remind guys hey i'm the
oldest guy out here i've played more
minutes than everybody
i'm available let's try to be more
available to our fans and to our
teammates
it almost seems like he's doing it on
purpose to deliver this message
like hey i'm old school and i agree with
you you show up for work i mean my
generation which is a lot older than
yours
we just showed up for work we didn't get
a pat on the back you just went
to work lebron is going to work but is
it
smart because the his goal is to win a
championship
and be an mvp in that order uh is it
smart
on his part to be showing up and playing
every night
i think it is for him specifically
because he has shown he and carl malone
are the only guys in league history that
i think we can say
they their body just seems to handle
wear and tear
differently than everyone else ever i
mean he slipped on a wet spot on
christmas day his first year with the
lakers and tore his groin aside from
that
he's been indestructible and so i i've
never
once watched a playoff series with
lebron and been like you know what he
looks tired
he plays more minutes and he looks fine
so i do think for certain guys
there is an element of you need to be
peaking at the end of the year
but the other thing and i would i'd have
this question for you dan
some of it seems like pseudo science and
guesswork because what what happened
with paul george a few days ago
embarrassing it was like it's it's like
okay he's at 32 and a half minutes not a
second more
do you know what it reminded me of 35
years ago
jordan when he was coming off the foot
injury and i only remember it because it
was in the last dance
he wanted to come back in the game in
the last minute remember he was arguing
with the coach
and the doctors came down they're like
no 18 minutes maximum i'm like
really with this is the but our science
is like
is like our train system how did you
move coal 100 years ago put it on a
train we haven't improved that
and we're not improving this either it's
like ah we guess an amount of minutes
and that's what it is
so i don't even people are like oh
you've got to listen to the science
but i think on the minute stuff the
science is
guessing i think it's just really
guesswork and i've never seen
evidence otherwise and in baseball dan
which i don't talk about a lot but you
do it somewhat
it's jeff passing wrote a great book
that since they have been more focused
on pitch counts
like pitch arm injuries have gone up so
some of this
i just don't think we have mastered yet
and i think
erring on the side of i'll play when i'm
healthy is pretty smart
he's nick wright co-host of first things
first on fox sports one kyrie irving had
uh something on instagram where he said
maybe we changed the logo from jerry
west to kobe bryant
could you see the league i know jerry
west would be fine with that because
jerry's embarrassed
to be the logo um and he brought kobe
into the league brought him into the
lakers
could you see where the league would
sign off on kobe replacing jerry west as
the logo
so a few things one is i read and i
didn't read a full article about it
uh but i did read yesterday that one of
the reasons it has stayed jerry west
is they don't have to pay any royalties
on that logo
and i think if you did it with kobe or
with anybody lebron's block on iguodala
michael jordan anything all of a sudden
you're gonna have to pay a royalty on
every and that seems untenable to go
from zero dollars
to even if it's just a small percentage
i just don't think that's realistic
i do think though if i'm going to touch
a third rail here
that kyrie in his comment on the idea
like his second line
he did raise it to me a valid point
which is
the nba is a black league it is an
overwhelmingly black league and the
success of the league
has been built for the vast majority by
black players
and it does seem a little anachronistic
that we've got a white dude from 1962
as the logo but i also think do you i
think a lot of people don't even know
that he's the logo
you know you know what i know it i think
most fans probably don't know that
that's an actual person
that in that logo yeah and
you know having spoke to jerry west
about this you know you can
tell where i don't think they conferred
with him
they basically just made him the logo
and then right
he didn't really acknowledge it for a
long time i mean growing up
i i sort of knew it was jerry because
there was a picture that accompanied
that logo picture but jerry is
embarrassed almost
to to bring that up and i agree with you
i don't know if the nba can go
hey we're going to have kobe as the logo
what's it going to cost
us right and but i don't know
i think kyrie's onto something but i
don't know if
if if he's on to something that will
actually come to fruition
well i wonder i i wonder if renaming
some of these awards
so the the larry o'brien
i don't think that's gonna change they
just named the finals mvp the bill
russell
you know that that happened a few years
ago i think that's good does and i
apologize for not knowing this
does league in vp does that trophy have
a
have an honorific because i think a lot
of people feel like kobe should have won
more than one league mvp he only won the
one
naming that after him almost as a i do
feel like there should be something done
for kobe
and i do feel like we should maybe
update some of these names to the more
modernized nba but i don't know if the
logo
is what they're going to do with it yeah
i don't see it happening but
i look i appreciate what kyrie
that kyrie has a personality i don't
always agree with it
but that he does he is a thinker um
sometimes he thinks too much sometimes
he doesn't think enough
but you know that he was it's a nice
gesture on his part
i and kyrie it was if you remember after
kobe's passing
kyrie took some time away and kyrie was
exceptionally close with kobe and i
think kyrie
we don't look at it because he's so much
smaller but
he's modeled a lot of his game after
kobe even though the games are different
yeah i listen just because
sometimes the people who have at times
the worst
ideas often are also the people that
come up with some of the best ideas
and so i i feel like this happens in
television
and radio production meetings a lot the
person that is most likely that when
they
throw something out there you're going
to be like why do we let that guy talk
is also a guy who about once a week
you're like oh that's brilliant and i
feel like you know kyrie throws a lot
out there some of it's a little wacky
but i think he was on to something here
without a doubt
i think it was last february paulie did
the research that
uh the all-star mvp is named after kobe
bryant
right they they changed it last year but
that's also
that's like a i know you're aware you
know what i mean
i know do something name the scoring
title after him i don't know
do something no like bradley beal come
on down and receive the kobe bryant
received the kobe bryant yeah yeah i
like it
uh do you want in on the j.j watt game
that we
we played we played it already where we
think he's going to end up do you do you
want to
sure yeah i'll be in you got one pick i
got one pick
there we go hold on here we go here's
here's the
nick wright green bay green bay okay
that's my pick going on a limb there i
don't know if it's a limb
i just think green bay they have good
cheese not good barbecue
come to kansas city for the barbecue jj
stay for the championships
that would be my recommendation well you
have lived in houston so you
you are yeah i lived there for four
years and ate what they
listen houston folks i understand it's
been tough times
i empathize with you immensely but texas
barbecue
is fraudulent and not it's not like
bad compared to its reputation it's bad
compared to food
it's just not good it's the hottest take
anyone's gonna deliver all year texas
barbecue
not good
thank you nick we appreciate your time
as always that's
the popular nick wright co-host of first
things first on fox sports